>> Greg: GLADYS KNIGHT WILL BE
SINGING THE NATIONAL ANTHEM AT
THE SUPER BOWL, WHICH IS A GREAT
CHOICE.
I WOULD HAVE SUNG IT MYSELF BUT
WHY STEAL TOM BRADY'S THUNDER?
OF COURSE THANKS TO A MEDIUM'S
BUSINESS MODEL IS CONFLICT, THE
ANTHEM CONTROVERSY STILL LINGERS
LIKE A BAD ODOR.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE STORIES WHERE
YOU CAN ONLY'S TRICK ALWAYS
BEGIN A SENTENCE WITH "YET THERE
ARE SOME WHO ARE CRITICIZING
KNIGHT FOR ACCEPTING THE HONOR."
WHENEVER I HEAR "HUM," I WONDER
WHO ARE THEY?
MULTIPLE ON KNOWN FORCES.
SOME SAY THIS, SOME SAY THAT.
SOME SAY REPORTERS WITHOUT
SOURCES.
SADLY WE ARE AT THE MERCY OF
SOME WHEN THERE AREN'T EVEN ANY.
IT'S A MAKE-BELIEVE.
HOW DID KNIGHT RESPOND TO SUCH
CRITICISM?
OF WHAT I PRAY THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM WILL BRING US
ALL TOGETHER IN A WAY NEVER
BEFORE WITNESSED AND WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD AND UNTANGLE THESE
TRUTHS WHICH MEANS SO MUCH TO
ALL OF US."
SHE SANG WHAT WE FEEL.
ENOUGH ALREADY.
LET'S MOVE ON.
I'M WITH HER.
SHE LOOKS GREAT, BY THE WAY.
>> Dana: AMAZING.
>> Greg: EVERY ISSUE, BE IT
IMMIGRATION, CLIMATE OR CRIME,
THE MEDIA DESIRES ONLY TWO
POSITIONS IN THE ANTHEM CASE
YOU'RE EITHER FOR STANDING
DURING THE ANTHEM OR AGAINST
POLICE.
HALLIDAY.
ONE 100% OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION CAN HOLD BOTH
POSITIONS.
GLADYS HOLDS BOTH, ADVOCATING
FOR JUSTICE AND THE ANTHEM.
I'M SURE SHE WILL DO A GREAT
JOB, PROBABLY EVEN BETTER THAN
ME EVEN THOUGH I'M SURE SOME
WILL DISAGREE.
I LOOK AT HER.
SHE HAS NOT AGED IN 40 YEARS.
IT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> Dana: WE HAVE TO ASK HER
WHAT HER SECRET IS.
>> Jesse: PROBABLY FACIALS.
I RECOMMEND THEM.
>> Dana: DID YOU GET ONE?
>> Jesse: NOT TODAY.
>> Greg: JUAN, THE GOOD NEWS
IS SHE'S DOING THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
BAD NEWS, MAROON 5 IS STILL
PLAYING AT HALFTIME.
>> Juan: I KNOW YOU DON'T LIKE
THEM.
I LOVE GLADYS KNIGHT.
I MUST SAY IT'S INTERESTING THE
CONTROVERSY, SOMEONE SAID IF SHE
WEARS A COLIN KAEPERNICK SHIRT,
THEY WILL APPLAUD HER.
SHE'S HAVING TO APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE
-- I THINK IN BLACK COMMUNITIES,
SAYING WHAT ABOUT COLIN
KAEPERNICK?
THAT'S MY OTHER ARTISTS REFUSED
TO PARTICIPATE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO ENDORSE THE IDEA
THAT IN THE NFL, EVERYTHING IS
NORMAL.
>> Greg: PURE PRESSURE.
AREN'T YOU AGAINST PEER
PRESSURE?
>> Dana: IF COLIN KAEPERNICK
WERE GIVEN A JOB, THEY'RE GOING
TO FIND ANOTHER REASON TO GO
AFTER HER FIRST SEEING THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD JUST GIVE HIM
A JOB FOR THE REST OF THE
SEASON?
GET IT.
THERE IS NO SEASON LEFT.
>> Greg: YOU COULD HAVE
TRICKED ME.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
HER MESSAGE IS CAN'T WE UNITE?
HER IDEAS THAT THE ANTHEM IS
SEPARATE FROM THE SOCIAL JUSTICE
ISSUES WHICH MAKES TOTAL SENSE.
>> Jedediah: SHE HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF FIGHTING FOR SOCIAL
INJUSTICE ISSUES.
RACIAL INJUSTICE, AIDS RESEARCH.
IT'S KIND OF SAD THAT PEOPLE ARE
STUNNED THAT SHE WOULD SAY THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM COULD BE USED AS
A UNIFYING FORCE FOR THE COUNTRY
SO REMOVED FOR THAT AND HAS MADE
THE NATIONAL ANTHEM SO DIVISIVE.
SHE'S SAYING YOU CAN BE A SOCIAL
JUSTICE WARRIOR AND SING THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM AND BE A
UNIFYING MOMENT, IT'S FOREIGN TO
PEOPLE.
IT'S SAD.
>> Greg: ALMOST EVERY SEGMENT
OR ISSUE WE TALK ABOUT HAS TO DO
AT ITS CORE WITH IDENTITY
POLITICS.
IT NEVER ENDS WELL.
MAYBE THIS WILL FINALLY BE A
HEALING MOMENT.
I HATE TO SAY HEALING MOMENTS.
>> Jesse: I WAS GOING TO USE
ANOTHER ANALOGY.
I THINK GLADYS PUT THE LAST
SHOVEL OF DIRT ON KAEPERNICK'S
GRAVE.
HERE'S WHY.
KAEPERNICK IS OVER.
NO ONE CARES ABOUT KAEPERNICK
ANYMORE.
NONE OF THE PLAYERS KNELT BARELY
AT ALL THIS YEAR.
IT HASN'T REALLY BEEN A
CONTROVERSY MUCH THIS YEAR AT
ALL.
EXCEPT FOR THE EAGLES DIDN'T GO
TO THE WHITE HOUSE BUT ON THE
FIELD, PLAYERS NOT KNEELING
ANYMORE.
KAEPERNICK, HE'S NEVER COMING
BACK TO THE NFL.
LIKE YOU SAID, THE ONLY PEOPLE
MAKING A BIG FUSS ABOUT IT ARE A
FEW PEOPLE ON TWITTER.
GLADYS KNIGHT IS WELL-RESPECTED,
SOCIAL MEDIA WARRIOR LIKE
MYSELF.
SHOT DOWN ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
AND REPEATED THE TALKING POINT
THAT I HAVE BEEN USING THE
ENTIRE YEAR.
GLADYS, THANKS FOR WATCHING AND
LISTENING.
THE ANTHEM IS A MOMENT OF
NATIONAL UNITY AND THAT'S WHERE
EVERYBODY SHOULD COME TOGETHER
AND YOU CAN TALK ABOUT SOCIAL
JUSTICE AFTERWARDS.
>> Greg: I THINK THERE WERE
THREE MOMENTS IN WHAT YOU